un soutien financier et et logistique
externe l'Iran a-t-il été selon vous
associé à la préparation de cette
attaque faut-il y voir comme l'ont
suggéré certains observateurs une
opération visant à torpiller le
rapprochement entre en cours entre
Israël et l'Arabie Saoudite ensuite
Israël est en train d'organiser sarost
après des bombardements massifs sur la
bande de Gaza il a été demandé à la
population d'évacuer la partie nord on
s'attend à une opération terrestre de
grande ampleur quelles sont les options
militaires qui s'offre à Israël et quel
serait les buts d'une telle opération si
l'objectif est d'éradiquer le Hamas en
tant qu'acteur politique et militaire en
éliminant ses dirigeants et une partie
de ses combattants comment y parvenir
sans causer d'innombrables victimes
civiles dans la population de Gaza il y
a en outre l'immense difficulté posée
par les otages parmi lesquels figurent
des Français miashem franco-israélienne
de 21 ans est apparu dans une vidéo
diffusée hier par l'organisation
terroriste et on a appris aujourd'hui
que nous déplurons déjà 21 ms mort et 11
disparus à ce jour je voudrais formuler
ici mes chers collègues un bref
commentaire
personnel à l'horreur à l'horreur du
attaque du Hamas faite de meurtrre
d'enfants parfois encore bébés s'ajoute
ce crime de la prise en otage ce mode
opératoire confirme que le Hamas ne
différ en rien de daesh comme français
nous avons vu des terroristes mitrailler
notre jeunesse au Bataclan comment ne
pas ressentir la même douleur et la même
révolte en voyant des terroristes
mitrailler la jeunesse d'Israël dans une
fête
dans les maisons dans les berceaux ou
encore hier soir ces images que nous
avons tous vu de supporter suédois
assassinés mitraillés en pleine rue j'en
reviens à la situation sur le terrain
car comme les élus comme élus nous ne
devons pas perdre de vue la dimension
terriblement concrète de cette tragédie
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur nous pensons que
le risque d'un embrasement général de la
région est réel les escarmouches ont
commencé à la frontière nord et le
hzbollah soutenu par l'Iran a annoncé
des représailles massives si l'armée
israélienne pénétrait dans la bande de
Gaza Israël serait-elle serait-il prêt à
assumer un affrontement direct ou
indirect avec l'Iran et enfin si l'idée
d'une paix paraît plus loin que jamais
dans ces heures sombres ne renonçons
jamais à l'espérer Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur votre him national
s'intitule aticva l'espoir et je crois
que c'est honoré la mémoire des
fondateurs de l'État d'Israël et de tous
ceux qui en France depuis 1948 ont
soutenu le droit des Israéliens à vivre
en paix sur la terre d'Israël que de
garder l'espoir un jour la paix puisse
advevenir au Proche Orient la France a
constamment réaffirmé son attachement à
la solution à de deux états elle nous
semble la seule voie pour parvenir à une
coexistence pacifique entre israélien et
Palestiniens et c'est pourquoi nous
observons avec préoccupation les
préparatives en cours nous reconnaissons
bien sûr le plein droit d'Israël à rosté
pour ceux de nos compatriotes qui
suivent cette audition je rappelle que
le nombre de morts tué par le Hamas
équivaudrait à l'échelle de la France à
plus de 10000 morts et si nous Français
voyons de nos compatriotes être
massacrés dans ces conditions inhumaines
ne serions-nous pas tentés par
laariposte la plus ferme Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur nous comprenons la
nécessité militaire pour Israël de
détruire le hamass comme responsable
politique comme ami d'Israël notre
devoir est de vous demander comment que
se passera-t-il ensuite si tsal entre
dans Gaza nous savons que le Hamas ne
reculera devant aucune lâcheté et se
servira de la population de Gaza comme
bouclier humain comment Israël va-t-il
éviter de tomber dans le piège que le
que tend le ass et tous ceux qui le
soutiennent ce piège de la communication
et de la radicalisation il souhaite en
fin de compte un affrontement global
entre le monde arabe et Israël voire
évidemment entre le monde arabe et les
pays occidentaux après votre propos
liminire Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
donnerai la parole à mes collègues pour
des échanges de questions et de réponses
et je vous rappelle à toutes et à tous
que cette audition est captée et
diffusée sur la le site internet du
Sénat Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je vous
laisse la
parole
merci Monsieur cédricin président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat
mesdames les sénatrices et monsieurs les
sénateurs merci pour votre invitation à
cette importante réunion je saisis cette
occasion pour vous remercier de votre
soutien de votre solidarité que vous
avez témoigné suite à l'attaque
terroriste la plus tragique de
l'histoire d'Israël par empleur de sa
barbarie et son bilan humain aussi a été
très sensible à l'hommage fort que le
président du Sénat monsieur Gérard
Larcher a rendu en séance publique
mercredi dernier au victime
israélienne mesdames messieurs alors
qu'Israël a progressivement repris le
contrôle et sécurisé les zones
frontalière avec la bande de Gaza que
les terroristes avaient infiltré
l'ampleur du massacre perpétré par le
Hamas a été révélé il s'agit d'une
attaque meurtrière et barbare rappelant
le modus operand de l'État islamique
initié par des organisations terroristes
dirigées par le Hamas une attaque lancée
sans aucun prétexte légitime ni action
provocative préalable de la part
d'Israël cette attaque révèle une fois
de plus le vrai visage de ces
organisations terroristes à savoir des
groupes sanguinaires et incontrôlables
issus de la même branche que l'État
islamique dépourvu de toute inhibition
morale motivé par la haine et le désir
de blesser les citoyens israéliens par
tous les moyens et provoquer la
destruction de l'État
d'Israël il est à rappeler que le Hamas
ne se préoccupe pas de la sécurité ou du
bien-être de sa population civile dans
la bande de Gaza il ne les considère que
comme des pions à exploiter dans ses
efforts pour nuire aux citoyens
israéliens à ce jour nous pleurons plus
de 1400 civils assassinés parmi lesquels
des bébés des enfants des femmes et des
personnes âgées et même des rescapés de
la
Choa les plans du Hamas retrouvé sur les
corps des terroristes prouve que le
Hamas avait parfaitement planifié la
mort et la prise d'otage de civils en
ciblant intentionnellement les femmes et
les
enfants des familles entières ont été
décimées dans leur maison environ 260
jeunes ont été abattu lors d'un festival
de musique au moins 3500 personnes ont
été blessées et beaucoup aussile encore
entre la vie et la mort on décomte 199
personnes kidnappées vers Gaza de 43
nationalités différentes sans que l'on
connaisse leur sort alors que le bilan
des victimes françaises tué durant les
attaques meurtriè du Hamas
salourdi avec 21 morts et 11 disparus
selon le K d'orset je tiens à présenter
nos plus sincères condoléances aux
familles françaises deuillé et exprimer
toute e notre compassion aux familles
des otages français dans ce moment
tragique plus de 6600 roquetes et
missiles ont été tiré à ce jour et
continuent à nous de nous attaquer sans
distinction sur notre
population cont tenu de ces
circonstances Israël est en guerre
contre les organisations terroristes de
la bande de Gaza le Hamas qui exercit
son pouvoir dans la BAT de Gaza où il
contrôle tous les aspects de la vie
depuis 16 ans est à l'origine de cette
attaque et sera tenu pour responsable
des conséquences de ces attaques les
dirigeants du Hamas portent l'entière
charge de la détor
détériorisation actuelle de la situation
et des mesures qu'Israël doit prendre
pour y répondre Israël fera tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour protéger ses
citoyens et son territoire à savoir
faire tomber le Hamas détruire ses
infrastructures militaire et éliminer la
menace terroriste que la bande de Gaza
fait peser sur ses citoyens
en même temps Israël déploiera tous les
efforts possibles pour protéger ses
otages ses frontières et ses
citoyens alors on parle beaucoup de la
situation humanitaire ces derniers jours
n'oublions pas que suite aux attaques
terroristes et au tir de roquettes qui
sont toujours en train de s'abattre sur
Israël des dizaines de milliers
d'Israéliens ont été déplacés de leur
maison dans les localités entourant la
bande de Gaza et dispersé dans dans
divers a pris abri à travers le pays en
outre en raison des attaques continues
du hezbola sur la frontière nord et du
risque aigu d'escalade qu'elle
représente des milliers de résidents des
localités de la frontière nord ont été
déplacés et de nombreux autres viennent
s'y ajouter chaque jour et n'oublions
pas que le tir des missiles et roquettes
sur la population israélienne continue
pendant que je vous
parle comme vous le savez bien les
organisations terroristes opèent sent
est délibérément à partir de zones
peuplées de civiles et à proximité de
bâtiments et d'institutions humanitaires
qu'elle
instrumentalise néanmoins l'armée
israélienne prend toutes les mesures
possibles conformément au droit
international pour éviter des perte
civil ces mesures comprennent
l'avertissement préalable lorsque cela
est possible des actions menées par
l'armée contre le Hamas qui pourrai
causer des dommages à des personnes non
appliquées en conséquence les forces de
défense israéliennes ont averti les
habitants de la de Gaza et l'ont demandé
de se rendre dans la zone située au sud
de la ville de Gaza pour les protéger et
les épargneré de tout danger ces
avertissements ont été diffusés en
langue arabe par divers canaux
médiatiques notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux ainsi que par l'intermédiaire de
la société civile et des organisations
internationales cependant le Hamas s'est
adressé aux habitants de Gaza qu'il
gouverne pour leur interdire d'évacuer
surtout il a appelé les habitants à ce
qu'ils appellent se fondre dans la
Résistance en agissant de la sorte le
Hamas peut continuer à instrumentaliser
les Gazaoui comme bouclier humain pour
ses activités meurtrières en outre de
plus en plus de témoignages indiquent
que le Hamas entrave voir empêche par la
force le déplacement de la population
civile vers la partie sud de la bande de
Gaza
bref tandis que
Israël fait tout le nécessaire pour
protéger sa population le Hamas fait
tout pour éviter la protection de sa pro
population et terroriser les civils en
Israël il est le seul responsable de
cette
situation je rappellerai aussi que le
Hamas détient au moins 199 otages dans
de très mauvaises conditions
humanitaires sans aucun respect du droit
international qui d'ailleurs interdit la
prise d'otage civil dans un conflit
armée israël considère le Hamas comme
entièrement responsable de leur suivi et
de leur bon
traitement vous m'vez posé question sur
l'embrasement et
euh sur la sur la frontière Nord alors
dans les jours qui viennent de s'écouler
des missiles antichar et des obus de
mortriers ont été tirés depuis le
territoire libanais sous les auspices du
Hezbollah sur les positions de l'armée
de défense israélienne et ce alors que
des terroristes ont continuer de tenter
de s'infiltrer en Israël les forces de
défense israéliennes ont réosté en
ciblant les sources des tirs et en
contrecarent l'infiltration des
terroristes ces derniers jours le
ministre israélien des Affaires
étrangères eloren a accueilli en Israël
plusieurs ministres des Affaires
étrangères venus témoigner leur
solidarité dont la ministre française
des Affaires étrangères Madame Catherine
Colona la visite en Israël du président
des États-Unis est attendue
demain pour votre question sur l'Iran
les organisations terroristes impliquées
sont des branches du régime d'Ayatollah
de en Iran qui encourage de manière
proactive les activités terroristes en
Israël et contre des cibles israéliennes
et juives dans le monde entier le Hamas
n'aurait pas été en mesure de mener
cette attaque meurtrière sans le
financement le soutien logistique et les
armes qu'il a reçu de l'Iran de l'Iran
la République islamique d'Iran porte la
responsabilité directe des capacités du
Hamas et par conséquent la
responsabilité de de l'utilisation que
le Hamas a faite de ses moyens
il va de soi également pour le Hizbollah
qui constitue le bras long du régime
iranien au Liban qui a annoncé être
responsable de plus que 10 attaques
perpétuées à l'encontre d'Israël ces
derniers jours y compris de tir de
missilees antichar et de mortiers ainsi
que des tentative d'infiltration
terroriste ces initiatives sont menées
sous la tutelle et le soutien de l'Iran
et mettent en danger le Liban et ses
habitants merci et si vous voulez
maintenant je suis prêt à recevoir des
questions euh vous merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur j'ai déjà un certain
nombre de questions mais vous pouvez
évidemment continuer à vous inscrire je
voudrais quand même saluer la présence
parmi nous du président du groupe
d'amitié France Israël Roger carucci qui
désormais fait partie de cette
commission euh donc j'ai plusieurs
demandes de parole et je commence par
Marie harlette Carlotti oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur au nom du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain je
tenais à vous exprimer notre entière
solidarité avec le peuple d'Israël qui a
été atrocement attaqué par le groupe
terroriste du Hamas entre prant des
milliers de morts innocents et mutilant
des femmes des enfants et des bébés
aujourd'hui notre pensée va aussi vers
les otages pour lequel tout doit être
entrepis pour leur libéralisation leur
libération excusez-moi nous partageons
avec vous cette angoisse parce que nous
avons aussi là des ressortissant
français les actions du Hamas que nous
condamnons avec la plus grande fermeté
et dont la seule intention est de
détruire Israël derent aussi la cause
palestinienne en l'islamisant et en
prenant les populations palestiniennes
en en otage vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure et c'est pourquoi il faut que on
le dise ici que l'attachement à la cause
palestinienne d'une partie de la
communauté internationale ne doit pas
être confondu avec la justification des
actes terroristes du Hamas Israël a le
droit de se défendre et quoi que l'on
puisse penser de la politique du premier
ministre monsieur netanahou le moment
venu les Israéliens feront
démocratiquement leur propre choix
aujourd'hui l'heure est uniquement à la
solidarité avec Israël deux questions
monsieur ou trois rapidement je reprends
ce qu'a dit tout à alure le président
pensez-vous que l'attaque d'Israël par
le Hamas aurait pu aurait dû être prévu
par les services de renseignement pour
nous ça nous paraît impensable
pouvez-vnous nous en dire plus sur ce
point deuxièmement est-ce que je veux
dire quelque chose mais c'est un astre
peut-être mort l'Autorité palestinienne
peut-elle encore jouer un rôle
d'interlocuteur aura-t-elle un rôle à
jouer demain et dans quelles conditions
et puis vous avez déclaré que la France
pouvait avoir une influence dans le
conflit de quel ordre et qu' a pu vous
apporter la présence de la ministre des
affaires étrangères en
Israël merci beaucoup je vous propose de
faire des séries de deux questions
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur et puis après
vous permettre de répondre au fil du
donc la la question suivante donc pour
Pascal Alizard merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je fais
mi les propos de ma collègue Marie
Arlette Carlotti sur et du président
d'ailleurs sur le soutien et la
solidarité que nous vous exprimons j'ai
eu aussi l'occasion de le faire je vous
l'ai dit il y a quelques instants en
tant que représentant spécial pour les
affaires méditerranéennes à l'OSCE
j'aurais en fait deux questions à à vous
poser question qui se regroupe la
première c'est à votre avis existe-t-il
encore un camp de la paix chez les
Palestiniens ça rejoint un petit peu le
propos précédent ou des personnes avec
lesquelles vous pouvez dialoguer en tant
que représentant spécial j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire travailler ensemble
des parlementaires Israéliens et des
membres du Conseil national palestinien
c'était à Marrakech il y a 3 ans ça
semble très très lointain est-ce que
c'est encore envisageable des pays
arabes aussi s'était récemment rapproché
d'Israël bon il y a un pas en arrière
est-ce que c'est une posture est-ce que
c'est durable mais peut-on travailler en
fait à réouvrir une discussion et et le
dernier point mais il est en relation
avec le précédent la Chine entretient
avec Israël des relations notamment
économiques mais vient de rappeler son
soutien à la juste cause je cite hein du
du peuple palestinien et pensez-vous que
la Chine va jouer un rôle diplomatique
dans cette crise alors qu'en fait tout
le monde sait qu'elle s'est récemment
rapproché de l'Iran et de l'Arabie
Saoudite je vous
remercie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je vous
laisse la parole oui merci pour vos
questions c'est ouvert oui
eu alors la question de la surprise euh
certes il y avait une surprise est-ce
qu'on a des renseignements préalables
qui ont été mal vu ou mal euh lu ou mal
analysé c'est la grande question que
nous tous israéliens se pose et certes
une enquête approfondie va être faite à
ce sujet parce que tous les Israéliens
demandent des réponse et à comprendre
comment est-ce que plus que 1400
citoyens ont été massacrés
euh mais pour le moment les les efforts
sont pour autour de de l'armée pour
gagner cette cette guerre donc je n'ai
pas de réponse à part reconnaître le
fait qu'il y a eu certes une défaillance
d'ailleurs j'ai vu aujourd'hui que le
chef du renseignement militaire a même
dit qu'il prend sur lui-même la
responsabilité il dit oui c'est c'est
inadmissible et j'ai vu aussi que le le
chef des service de sécurité euh aussi a
dit la même chose donc enfin on est bien
conscient qu'il a eu des une grande
défaillance et qu'il y a des
responsabilités à à é tirer mais on
n'est pas pour le moment au stade de de
voilà de de de de démontrer tout ce qui
s'est passé ou de comprendre tout ce qui
s'est passé mais mais je vous garantis
que
la la vérité va voir lumière voilà c'est
ça parce que nous exisons tous
premièrement nous israéliens de de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et
comment est-ce qu'on a été surpris de de
telle ampleur alors c'est la question du
rôle de l'Autorité palestinienne
euh premièrement il y a un problème il
faut admettre de de légitimité de
de la la direction de de du président de
l'Autorité palestinienne par car depuis
15 ans plus que 15 ans il y a pas eu
d'élection
présidentielle sous l'autorité
palestinienne
donc si on parle de relancer un
processus politique
euh il faut un partenaire qui qui serait
vraiment
euh en mesure voilà de prendre des des
engagements et être suffisamment
courageux pour pour prendre des des des
des des décisions qui seraient
historiques pour le moment ce que nous
voyons c'est que le l'Autorité
palestinienne avec l'aide internationale
qu'elle reçoit il faut bien dire ça elle
paye des pensions ou des allocations aux
familles des des des terroristes qui
sont arrêtés dans les dans les prisons
euh en Israël ça je trouve très très
grave et maintenant on comprend beaucoup
mieux l'ampleur on a soulevé ça ce ce
problème déjà à plusieurs reprises mais
euh vous comprenez bien que si une si un
terroriste sait que s'il est arrêté sa
famille va avoir une pension ou une
allocation il sera encore plus motivé de
de de de commettre un acte terroriste
donc il faut voir aussi ça c'estàd que
l'Autorité palestinienne a un rôle pour
le moment qui encourage la
radicalisation de la population et des
actes
terroristes et ce problème bien sûr a
éta soulevé également auprès des
autorités françaises c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau je je je je tiens à
souligner
eu et pour la question du rôle de la
France alors euh premèrement la France
et exprimé sa solidarité son soutien et
c'est très important surtout en ce
moment très difficile cela compte
beaucoup pour la population israélienne
car la France est un un pays proche avec
lequel et on a des des relations dans
pratiquement tous les domaines et mais
au-delà de la solidarité qui et du
soutien moral c'est important que la
France aussi continue à soutenir le
droit d'Israël de se défendre et de de
de de répliquer tel qu'il est nécessaire
pour éradiquer euh le terrorisme dans la
bande de Gaza je noterai également le
rôle de la France pour vis-à-vis des
états eu de la région pour éviter un
embrasement cela a été fait et nous
apprécions beaucoup cette intervention
et pour la visite de la ministre Colona
en Israël c'était une une visite de
solidarité essentiellement avec le
peuple d'Israël c'est important je suis
bon je je suis sûr qu'elle a euh
élaborer la question des otages et et
d'autres sujets eu voilà de d'intérêt
commun eu alors pour la question des du
camp pour la paix est-ce encore
envisageable monsieur c'est c'est une
bonne question moi j'y crois et parce
qu'en fin de
compte c'est ce qu'il faut aboutir il
faut aboutir la paix donc qu'il faut un
camp de paix et je pense
qu'essentiellement euh non seulement du
côté israélien il y a la majorité qui
veul la paix ou peut-être tous les
Israéliens veulent la paix mais je crois
qu'aussi la majorité des Palestiniens
veulent veulent la paix euh donc c'est
un moment difficile pour tous pour tous
tous ceux qui croit à la paix certes
et mais comme il était mentionné que
notre h national c'est latiqueval
l'espoir et ben on a l'espoir
que que c'est possible
et la Chine est-ce qu'elle a un rôle
diplomatique non pas vraiment la
Chine je crois qu'elle
laisse les États-Unis et les puissances
européennes à à intervenir
diplomatiquement dans la région la la
SNE jusqu'aujourd'hui n'a pas joué un
rôle diplomatique euh même si bon dans
la question de l'Arabie Saoudite et
l'Iran ils étaient un peu
l'intermédiaire mais mais c'est ça va
pas au-delà de cela je crois pas que la
Chine a une volonté premièrement de
d'être un acteur c'est ça il n' a pas de
volonté merci beaucoup donc la parole
François bonau pardon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur notre groupe s'associe aux
propos qui ont été
tenu par par nos prédécesseurs il est
clair qu'attaquer Israël c'est c'est
attaquer tout l'Occident à travers les
valeurs qui sont
défendues la la colonisation a connu une
progression extrêmement importante ces
ces 20 dernières années il suffit de
regarder la carte pour s'en convaincre
ou d'aller sur
place cette protection des colonies
mobilise de de nombreux soldats est-ce
que cette protection n'a pas fragilisé
le système de Défense israélien par
rapport par rapport à la à la bande de
Gaza notamment prière question 2uxè
question est-ce
que compte tenu euh des événements je
dirais actuels et à venir est-ce que
certains pays qui ont signé les accords
d'Abraham vont pouvoir les maintenir oou
est-ce qu'il y a il y a un risque de ce
côté-là merci François Jean-Marc
lesessousfor pas une demande ah bon
alors Michel
gréum merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur tout d'abord
merci pour vos propos préliminaires
c'est un conflit terrible barbare
inhumain qu'il faut condamner avec des
mots forts oui il n'y a aucun doute il
faut que nous soyons tous au côté
d'Israël pour éradiquer définitivement
le Hamas cette organisation islamique
terroriste et mettre hors état de nuire
tous ceux qui la composent mais
parallèlement nous devons trouver une
solution à ce conflit une solution pour
que la paix revienne durablement l'ONU
et l'Union européenne doivent mettre
tout en œuvre pour qu'une solution
pérenne aboutisse et qu' cc de feu
interviennne
rapidement en effet comme dans tous les
conflits il y a des victimes civil
collatéral celles et ceux qui n'ont rien
demandé à part vivre une vie paisible et
vous l'avez dit en famille dans la paix
et fraternité que ce soit au sein du
peuple
israélien que palestinien rappelons
qu'il est nécessaire de respecter la 4e
Convention de Genève relative à la
protection des personnes civiles en
temps de guerre de plus il y a nécessité
de faire libérer les les aotage du Hamas
le plus rapidement possible pour leur
sécurité ce samedi la rapport ur spécial
des Nations Unies Francisca albanis a
alerté l'ONU sur un risque de nettoyage
ethnique à Gaza les Nations Unis quant à
eux parlent d'une catastrophe
humanitaire inédite Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur mon groupe politique à
plusieurs reprises s'est positionné sur
une solution à deux états quelle est la
police la position d'Israël à ce sujet à
votre avis quelle fra peut-on lever pour
aboutir à une solution de paix pérenne
et aboutir à ce que ces deux peuples
puissent coexister et enfin quelles
mesures sont prises aujourd'hui par
Israël pour éviter de nouvelles victimes
civiles et pour la libération des otages
merci merci Michel Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur
oui alors sur la question
des de la répartition des forces de
l'armée entre la sis jourdanie et la
bande de Gaza c'est une des questions
que l'enquête qui va être lancée
sur surtout le fond de cette surprise
don on a parlé évoqué avant euh va
devoir regarder c'est est-ce que
effectivement il y avait suffisamment de
de force euh le long de la bande de Gaza
surtout s'il y avait déjà des
renseignements de de d'une possible
attaque euh donc je je n'ai pas la
réponse mais je suis sûr que c'est une
des question une des questions qui va
être examinée euh pendant cette enquête
sur la question des accords d'Abraham
alors euh je je suis convaincu que les
intérêts des des partenaires de des
accords d'Abraham sont sont forts et ils
ont l'intérêt de de les maintenir
notamment également l'Arabie Saoudite
qui était en cours de de normalisation
des relations avec Israël bon pour le
moment évidemment c'est c'est c'est gelé
si on peut dire mais je pense que c'est
une mesure temporaire et car les comme
je dis bien les intérêts de de ces pays
d'avoir une stabilité dans la région et
de prospérité économique et également
confrontter la la menace iranienne sont
beaucoup plus forts que
euh que voilà que de ce qui se passe
avec le Hamas d'ailleurs aucun de ces
pays-là ouvertement dira qu'il qu'il
qu'il soutient le Hamas tous comprennent
très bien que ce que justement c'est le
le danger qui que présente le Hamas
comme organisation terroriste qui qui
qui présente également à leur propre
dans leur propre pays
donc pour le moment c'est c'est c'est
c'est gelé mais c'est mais mais c'est
voilà je crois que ça va relancer
prochainement alors la question sur
enfin c'était une question plusieurs
questions que vous avez
soulever oui bien évidemment je suis
tout à fait d'accord nous somm d'accord
qu' en à la fin du conflit il fautveroir
une solution politique et la solution
des deux états est certainement une
solution qui est sur la table il y a
peut-être d'autres mais
il faudra bien sûr aboutir à une
solution politique du conflit ça je est
tout à fait engagé avec le Hamas bien
sûr il est hors de question parce que il
est il il ne reconnaît ni l'existence de
l'État d'Israël ni le veut la paix avec
Israël et donc il y a aucune négociation
qui peut être possible avec lui mais
avec l'Autorité
palestinienne on espère pouvoir oui
relancer un processus
politique
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur Guillaume
Gontard
oui merci merci Monsieur Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur à mon tour et comme j'ai
pu l'exprimer en séance publique
mercredi dernier je tiens au nom du
groupe écologiste que je que je préside
à vous témoigner toute notre solidarité
face à l'épreuve sans précédent qui
afflige Israël et son peuple toutes nos
pensées évidemment au victimes et au aux
otages nous sommes profondément attachés
à la sécurité d'Israël et et du peuple
juif est branlé le 7 octobre par les
attaques terroristes abominables
conduites par le Hamas et rien ne peut
et ne pourra justifier ces attaques
abominables pour garantir cette sécurité
votre gouvernement a choisi une forme de
réponse extrêmement forte qui a déjà
fait plusieurs milliers de victimes et
qui devrait conduire prochainement une
opération militaire terrestre dans la
bande de de Gaza face à ces attaques
terroristes du Hamas sans précédent le
droit à la défense et à votre sécurité
est évidemment incontestable cependant
nous nous inquiétons d'une réponse qui
ne permettrait pas de respecter le le
droit international tout d'abord parce
que des milliers de vies sont en jeu des
vies de civiles Palestiniens femmes
enfants vieillards par milliers des vies
de soldats israéliens et de réservistes
dans des proportions qui dépendront de
l'ampleur de vos objectifs de objectifs
militaires que vous ne pouvez pas nous
détailler ici et évidemment nous le
comprenons bien ce choix nous interroge
aussi car nous portons la conviction
profonde qu'une nouvelle guerre contre
la terreur ne résoudra hélas rien
l'histoire des dernières déc nous a
montré que les démocraties et les armées
régulières ne peuvent pas gagner ces
guerres pas même la plus grande armée du
monde depuis la prise du pouvoir du
Hamas à Gaza les opérations militaires
dans la bande de Gaza interviennent
régulièrement plomb Durc en 2008 pilier
de défense en 2012 bordure protectrice
en 2014 et désormais glave de fer et
hélas ne change pas grand-chose tel
leadre dont les têtes repoussent si le
Hamas est temporairement affaibli il en
ressort à terme nourri par la haine et
renforcé et pour encore quel futurs
horaires la réponse n'est évidemment pas
simple et certainement politique comment
retrouver le chemin de l'espoir vous
l'avez un petit peu esquissé donc
j'avais quelques questions est-il
possible de combattre le Hamas à Gaza
sans imposer une punition collective
insoutenable au peuple palestinien et
quelle précaution prend votre état-major
pour épagner des civils qui ne peuvent
pas quitter la bande de
Gaza nous considérons également que que
seule une solution politique à deux
étapes pe garantir la sécurité d'Israël
le gouvernant que que vous représentez
partage-t-il cette ominion vous l'avez
un petit peu
exprimé quelles sont également les les
conditions selon vous pour espérer
incesser le feu et notamment avec quel
interl interlocuteur pardon vous en avez
un peu parlé israël peut-il construire
la paix et comment selon vous contrer le
Hamas
durablement vous l'avez dit une majorité
veut la paix et donc l'espoir est
certainement là
merci merci Guillaume Nicole
Duranton merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur donc mon groupe
RDPI s'associe effectivement et condamne
fermement donc les attaques du Hamas
envers Israël et vous apporte toute
notre solidarité donc l'attaque sans
précédent du Hamas risque de saper les
tentatives de normalisation entre Israël
et l'Arabie Saoudite
poids lourd du Moyen-Orient ces
négociations en cours parinées par les
États-Unis pourrait voir l'Arabie
Saoudite reconnaître Israël en échange
de garantie de sécurité américaine donc
le 20 septembre le prince héritier
saoudien Mohamed Ben salam a fait état
de progrès avec le rapprochement avec
Israël mais a exigé des avancées sur la
question palestinienne considérant
considéré pardon comme une priorité par
son
père en ce sens le timing de l'attaque
du Hamas n'est pas un Odin selon
certains spécialistes donc qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui de la négociation
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
euh alors pour la première question je
voudrais souligner comme j'ai déjà
mentionné que Israël se soumet au droit
international et comme j'ai donné comme
exemple quand on envoie des tractes pour
avertir la population contre des des des
attaques c'est ce n'est pas requis par
le droit international c'est une
initiative quiisraël a inventé ce ce n'a
pas été fait par les forces alliées
quand ils ont attaqué Bagdad et Moussou
durant la guerre du Golf na pas été fait
dans d'autres régions du monde c'est une
invention israélienne qui qui démontre à
quel point nous nous nous vraiment nous
sommes sensibles pour éviter les pertes
civiles VI la petite différence oui
ok
et non non c'est bien alors les
opérations euh ne règlent rien vous avez
dit eu je crois que c'est aussi la leçon
que nous avons tirée c'est pour ça
qu'après 16 ans on veut changer le mode
operandi du traitement de ces attaques
terroristes qui seraient le subi parce
que si dans le passé on pass on pensait
que bon on va taper fort on va éliminer
les certains dirigeants et après ça va
se calmer en espérant que le Hamas
peut-être souhaite changer son attitude
de devenir un acteur politique on était
un peu sous cette
dillusion euh on voit que ce n'est pas
le cas
hein et donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je dis bien le paradigme
a changé c'estàd on va on peut pas se
permettre que de nouveau les les les
commoditaires de ces attaques
meurtrières vont rester en impunité car
on sait très bien que du moment que il y
aura un cesser le feu ils vont tout de
suite se remettre à à préparer la
prochaine attaque n'oublions pas qu'and
même temps il y a toujours des missiles
des roquites qui sont tirés du
territoire de de la bande de Gaza sur
Israël donc ça aussi faut il faut il
faut traiter euh parce qu'on peut
pas accepter que cela continue à
terroriser notre population donc la la
donne sera cette fois-ci différente et
bien sûr la la solution militaire ce
n'est pas la solution de tous les
problèmes mais c'est la la condition
préalable pour avoir une solution
politique voilà
euh alors est-ce que quelles sont les
conditions pour respérer le CESS le feu
le CESS le feu n'est pas l'ordre du jour
premièrement et puis euh si vous voulez
une situation idéal raisonnable et juste
c'est que le Hamas dit ok on relâche les
otages nous sortons de nos de nos cache
avec les mains avec les bras en l'air il
y aura le CER le feu et dans ce cas-là
on peut on peut imaginer une autre une
autre issue du conflit mais je crois pas
que c'est à l'ordre du jour donc
malheureusement ce n'est on n'est pas
dans cette direction
là alors pour l'Arabie Saoudite oui on
était très proche
d'un d'un accord d'une normalisation et
comme je je peux partager cette analyse
qui dit que le timing de cette attaque
de Hamas n'était pas euh hasard n'était
pas par hasard choisi pour ce moment-là
euh donc ça va retarder ce qui devait se
faire je crois pas que ça va euh
empêcher dans le futur un un
rapprochement et une normalisation de
entre Israël et l'Arabie sauduit parce
que les les les intérêts sont sont
beaucoup plus forts
merci merci merci Monsieur ambassadeur
Giselle
Jourda merci monsieur le Président je
souhaitais Monsieur l'Ambassadeur avoir
donc votre
éclairage dans cette situation
dramatique et connaître la nature des
relations donc avec la Russie ce qui me
paraît parfaitement important et je
souhaitais savoir quel témoignage vous
avez donc reçu en en octobre dernier aux
alentours du 7 donc de ce pays puisqu'on
peut au niveau de la Russie se dire que
cette situation dramatique peut
permettre à la Russie de se dédoiner
quelque part par rapport à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sur notre sol européen
avec l'Ukraine je souhaitais avoir votre
éclairage là-dessus merci
beaucoup merci Giselle euh Valérie
Boyet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur à mon tour de
vous dire toute notre solidarité notre
compassion pour les poogrommes
abominables que vous avez vécu et je
crois qu' ont saisi des
frroids le monde entier en tout cas une
partie du monde dont fait partie la
France euh je ne peux pas ne pas penser
à nos compatriotes français qui sont
nombreux et au désarroi dans
lequel cette guerre abominable cette
déclaration de guerre abominable et ses
conséquences sur le territoire d'Israël
même nous plongent en en tant que
Français en tant qu'amis Israël et en
tant que personnes qui avons énormément
d'amis Juifs parce que c'est de ça aussi
dont il s'agit on prend de leurs
nouvelles dès qu'on peut on tremble à
chaque fois qu'on allume la télévision
et on est plongé dans l'horreur pour
quelque chose à laquelle je crois que
personne n'aurait imaginé une horreur
pareille Israël vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur l'ambassadeur euh a
inventé quelque chose de totalement
inédit c'est-à-dire de prévenir les
populations civiles qu'elles doivent
être évacué puisque jamais au grand
jamais euh vous ne vous en prenez au
civil
euh cependant forcé de constater que
aujourd'hui ces populations n'ont nulle
part où aller puisque soit elles sont
retenues par le ramas soit les pays euh
à côté n'en veulent pas en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on nous relate euh et on
sait très bien que même si vous êtes en
facee de guerre même si le monde est
derrière vous pour pour pour cette
guerre en tout cas le nôtre euh c'est
aussi la paix à laquelle nous pensons
tous et c'est à l'après et que cet après
va dépendre en partie euh de la façon
devant laquelle se le ramas utilisera ou
non sa propre population comme bouclier
humain comme otage avec les otages
Israéliens et les otages internationaux
aussi qu'il détiennent donc ma question
est la suivante
savez-vous pouvez-vous nous nous en dire
plus
sur les pays qui seraient susceptibles
de de prendre ces population euh
et quel rôle les Américains précisément
vont-ils jouer ou en tout cas
ont-ils son sont-ils intervenus pour ces
populations pour le les les les jours
qui
viennent voilà je vous remercie merci
Valérie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
voudrais me permettre de compléter un
peu la la question de Giselle Jourda
Radio J hier annoncéit que le président
Zelenski avait demandé à faire une
visite en en Israël et que que vra
simpblement il lui aurait été répondu
que ce n'était pas le bon
moment est-ce que les événements de la
semaine dernière ont changé quelque
chose dans la position d'Israël vis-àvis
de l'Ukraine compte tenu du
positionnement de la Russie par rapport
à l'Iran et par rapport à des ventes
d'armes de l'Iran à la
Russie est-ce que cette situation a
évolué sur la la prudence qui avait été
en tout cas celle d'Israël vis-à-vis du
conflit ukrainien merci beaucoup et je
vous laisse répondre aux autres
questions
merci alors j'admets que je ne suis pas
expert dans les relations avec la Russie
c'est pas tellement ma compétence
et
cependant et aussi à votre question nous
avons des relations particulières avec
la Russie parce que c'est pas qu'on a
une une frontière géographique avec la
Russie mais nous avons quand même une
présence militaire pas loin de notre
frontière syanienne euh la Syrie oui
syranienne on dit syrienne pardon
syrienne euh ce qui fait que euh nous
devons tenir compte de cette présence en
Syrie euh il contrôle le le ciel
l'espace aérien de la Syrie et donc
c'est important d'être en coordination
[Musique]
euh reprocher étroite voilà avec avec
eux ce qui fait qu'aussi dans le
contexte du du conflit et de la guerre
en Ukraine notre position est plus euh
disons nuancée euh même si au niveau des
valeurs je crois que c'est clair de de
quel côté nous nous positionnons euh
alors cela à voir également avec la
proposition de la visite du du président
Zelenski
euh je pense pas que c'est le moment euh
idéal disons pour mener une telle visite
et mais bien sûr il sera je pense qu'il
sera venu dans des temps dans un temps
normal voilà quand les conditions le
permettront
euh alors pour la question oui de de
l'évacuation des de la population des de
Gaza euh je ne sais pas s'il y a des
pays qui sont qui qui seraient prêts à
prendre cette population
euh j'ai vu un propos de l'union de la
présence de l'Union européenne il y
avait quelque chose d' ce sujet n'est-ce
pas
non
ok en
général
je ça marche ou
pas marche il y a
coordination entre et les représentants
organisation internationale et et et
c'est depuis des années c'est pas
quelque chose à nouveau
et cette coordination mérite que il y a
des abris pour la population et
palestinien au sou de Gaza c'est pour
c'est pour laquelle qu'on a demandé que
la population de ville de Gaza et s ban
lieu et seront évacués et et au soude de
la bande pour que et ils et euh avoir
les les abris et préparer déjà pour eux
et euh autour ranunes et euh on sait que
missie goutièes et le secrétaire général
de l'UNU a mentionné que ce n'est pas et
un bon solution mais de quelle solution
il s'agit de laisser les population être
boucliers humain ça ça c'est une
solution ça c'est la proportionnalité
demandée
alors je trouve que au milieu de
situation très difficile on fait tout ce
qu'il faut et et nécessaire et vis-à-vis
une ennemi meurtrière et population qui
est pris autage par cette organisation
terroriste et j'ajouterai qu'on pas
demander la population de la ville de
Gaza de quitter la bande de Gaza mais
simplement de se déplacer 20 km hein
c'est comme Paris verersailles donc
c'est pas si compliqué que ça euh et
cela suffirait voilà donc il s'agit pas
de les expulser dans un autre pays ou de
les faire transférer dans un autre pays
simplement voilà 20 K dégager 20 km pour
pour euh pour pas être pour éviter les
pertes civiles
voilà
Roger carucci
oui Monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'abord un
élément quand même si les Israéliens
demandent au Gazaoui d'aller vers le sud
de la bande de Gaza c'est parce qu'en
réalité tous les
tunnels organisés par le ramas sont sur
Gaza City et pas vers le sud parce que
par définition ça n'intéressait pas le
ramass de faire des tunnels vers
l'Égypte donc forcément c'est la zone
des tunnels qui est la zone la plus
menacée par un conflit direct et c'est
donc de cette zone là que les Israéliens
demandent le départ de la population moi
je voudrais insister Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur sur qu'est-ce que on peut
faire dans les conditions actuelles pour
euh sauver ce qui peut l'être des
accords
d'Abraham il est clair j'ai organisé ici
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de réunions
euh auxquell participe des représentants
marocains émirati
Bini
bon un
élément quand même à noter c'est que
pour le moment je dis bien pour le
moment et malgré les manifestations on
le sait bien de la rue arabe très
sensible à la cause palestinienne pour
le moment je n'ai vu aucun gouvernement
pas plus marocain que
bariniirati par exemple annuler les
accords passés aucun voilà et j'ai bien
noté que le Prince Mohammed ben Salman
ne dit pas qu'il annule le processus il
dit on le suspend ce qui voudrait
laisser entendre
que si les choses venai enfin à
s'apaiser le processus pourrait
reprendre qu'est-ce que fait en en en
pratique si je peux me permetre de poser
la question et si vous pouvez répondre
Israël par rapport à tous ces états
arabes avec qui il avait très nettement
depuis 3 4 ans amélioré ses relations
qui évidemment sont soumis
à des médias ou une population très
sensible quand même à la cause
palestinienne qui ne rentre peut-être
pas dans le détail d'un certain nombre
d'éléments et qui bon peuvent faire
pression sur le gouvernement qu'est-ce
qu'Israël peut faire pour sauver les
accords d'Abraham parce que je suis
certain qu'après la phase actuelle le la
garde des accords d'Abraham change la
donne et l'image d'Israël à la fois avec
le monde arabe et avec le monde
occidental il y a il y a vraiment
quelque chose d'essentiel à sauvegarder
là est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce
que le le gouvernement israélien fait ou
peut faire en la
matière merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
peut-être bruno Sido et puis après je
vous laisserai
répondre merci monsieur le président euh
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure que euh le Hamas
continuait à bombarder euh Israël
et je voudrais vous poser une première
question c'est comment le Hamas
fait-il pour amasser autant d'armes sur
cette bande de Gaza alors même qu'on lui
dit que vous avez dépensé beaucoup
d'argent pour l'encercler ou alors
est-ce que c'est la marine israélienne
qui ne fait pas son travail c'est ma
première question la deuxème elle est
très simple euh vous allez attaquer la
bande de Gaza c'est ça semble clair vous
connaissez le les dégâts que peuvent
faire la communication les image et
cetera comment peut-on faire pour
arrêter cette communication en tempant
de guerre sur le champ de bataille après
tout il y a les pilones de téléphonie
mobile qu'on peut bloquer il y a
également les satellites on peut le les
demander leur demander aux
propriétairees de les arrêter ça a déjà
été fait donc envisagez-vous de faire
quelque chose pour qu'il a pas de
communication pendant les opérations
merci merci Monsieur ambassadeur à vous
la parole merci
euh alors comment saz les accords
d'Abraham alors je crois que plus que je
crois je sais que quand même les les
canaux de communication sont sont
ouverts nous avons toujours des
ambassades et dans dans dans tous ces
dans C dans les quatre pays des accords
d'Abraham et je crois qu'ussi les
États-Unis font pression sur ces sur les
pays des accords d'Abraham également sur
l'Arabie Saoudite de voilà de de
maintenir même si c'est en en cachette
ou en de manière plus plus discrète les
les les relations et surtout ne pas ne
pas
suspendre aussi c'est une suspension
c'est suspension temporaire donc il y a
des contacts mais bien sûr qui se font
en tout en discrétion et le rôle des
États-Unis à ce sujet est
important
c'est ça c'est donc j'insiste que même
s'il y a une
tension momentané
euh sur le long terme je les comme je
dis bien les intérêts des des des de ces
pays-là sont beaucoup plus forts de de
continuer le le rochement avec Israël
justement pour changer la donne dans
dans dans dans dans le proche orient
euh comment le Hamas a réussi à massé
temp de missile alors c'est une bonne
question euh vous savez c'est
c'est c'est pas si compliqué que ça en
fin de compte et justement on avait vu
cette vidéo qui a circulé je pense la
semaine dernière qu'on que on peut trans
transformer des tuyaux pour d'irrigation
ou des des tuyaux de enfin pour pour
canaliser de l'eau et les les
transformer en missiles ce sont pas des
missiles super sophistiqués téléguidés
et cetera
heureusement donc vous prenez un tuyau
en acier suffisamment fort vous remettre
de l'explosif et enfin je connais pas t
les détails mais ce que je veux dire
dire que c'est ça peut être assez
facilement dissimulé sous d'autres sous
d'autres apparences c'est pas que c'est
c'est pas que voilà il y a des un
missile complet et passé voilà sous nos
yeux sans qu'on sans qu'on s'aperçoit
mais c'est différents tous les éléments
qui qui qui fait que après on peut
construire dans dans dans des dans des
ateliers assez primitif en fin de compte
de faire monter ses ces moyens de
destruction
oui et comme vous avez vu dans cette
vidéo apparemment c'est ces tuyau de ces
tuyau d'au on été financé par l'aide
européenne
d'ailleurs à propos la question de
bloquer les communication et si on a les
moyens je peux pas dire mais si si c'est
ça sera possible c'est un autre question
de la démocratie est-ce que la
démocratie peut et bloquer les
communications et et et changer
et à cause de ça changit l'équilibrium
de de de la guerre et à propos qu'on est
un état démocrate démocratique et ça ça
pose une question est-ce queon peut le
est-ce que on voulons le faire on va
dire comme ça est-ce que nous voulions
le faire et et je dis rien à propos la
capabilité merci alors pour terminer
donc j'ai une demande de parole de
Jean-Baptiste Le
Moine merci beaucoup Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je m'assoucie pleinement
au propos de de Nicole Duranton sur la
solidarité exprimée par le le groupe
RDPI à la suite de de cette attaque
terroriste ignoble et nous sommes là
dans le temps court qui est celui des
conséquences de l'attaque
et de des opérations qui sont menées
euh pour y répondre néanmoins nous ne
devons pas oublier le le moyen terme et
le long terme puisque vous l'avez dit
vous-même euh à la fin du conflit il
faut une situation politique euh
néanmoins j'entends dans vos propos que
il y a
la solution à deux États mais vous
l'avez dit vous-même il y en a peut-être
d'autres et donc ça m'interroge sur la
volonté cor l'État d'Israël ou non de
mettre
fin justement une politique qui
peut-être
encourage un certain nombre de de
colonie à se développer or les Nations
Unies ont bien précisé que c'était aussi
un obstacle
majeur à l'instauration de la paix
durable et c'est cette paix durable
qu'on doit viser et
donc je sais que la commission des
affaires étrangères s'était rendue je
crois l'année dernière en déplacement
qu'elle avait pu constater sur le
terrain effectivement les effets de ce
type d'action et donc on voit bien qu'à
un moment quand on veut sortir d'un
conflit par le haut il faut que tout le
monde y mette du sien et de ce point de
vue-là qu'est prêt à faire l'état
d'Israël pour faciliter et bien la mise
en œuvre de la solution à deux États qui
est dans la communauté internationale
quand même largement
agréé merci Jean-Baptiste et pour
terminer la parole est au président
Cambon merci président euh effectivement
comme le rappelait Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
l'année dernière une délégation de la de
la Commission s'est rendu et j'en
faisait partie euh en Israël et a eu
l'occasion d'aller sur la bande de Gaza
je pense du reste que nous serons une
des dernières délégations parlementaires
à nous rendre à Gaza d'ici
longtemps ce que nous avons constaté
c'est qu'effectivement la situation
était assez dramatique mais ça tout le
monde le sait en revanche je souhaite
vous interroger sur l'aide au
développement que l'Europe et et la
France particulièrement
apporte au territoire palestinien et
deun manière générale à Gaza les
derniers chiffres vous les avez vu dans
la presse euh plus de près d'un un peu
moins d'un milliard de de dollars ont
été dépensés la France depuis 1999 je le
dis sous le contrôle du xori qui a été
rapporteur de ce budget pendant des
années c'était 500 millions depuis
1999 je dois dire que sur place nous
avons eu beaucoup de mal à nous rendre
compte de ce que le Hamas puisque c'est
lui qui est au commande à Gaza faisait
de cet argent car si je mets de côté le
CE ce qui était je ne sais pas ce qu'il
en est maintenant le magnifique centre
culturel français qui était juste en
face du siège du Hamas je pense pas je
pense qu'il a dû subir de beaucoup de
dommages et l'usine des EAU que la
France a financé nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion véritable de
constater la bonne utilisation de ces
crédits je mets de côté l'action de
l'unra que nous avons reçu ici en
commission et qui au niveau notamment de
l'éducation et des écoles faisait
certainement un très gros effort mais
comme notre commission a à examiner le
budget de l'aide au développement que
des questionnements très importants
interviennent au niveau européen et
compris à Bruxelles dans un certain
nombre de pays sur l'utilisation que la
Palestine de manière générale et Gaza
plus particulièrement fait de cet argent
quel est le sentiment de votre
gouvernement sur cette aide est-ce qu
quelle attitude un pays comme la France
doit avoir à la fois pour ne pas oublier
l'intérêt des populations civiles mais
ne pas donner des moyens euh à à ces à
ces gens de détourner une partie de
cette aide vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure au début de vos propos le fait
que euh
le au niveau de ramala on finançait les
familles des terroristes bien évidemment
tout ceci pose des questions à nos
concitoyens qui se demandent si
véritablement l'aide de l'Europe ne sert
pas à favoriser et à développer le
terrorisme quel est le sentiment de
votre gouvernement Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur monsur
merci
euh alors on dit souvent que les
colonies c'est l'obstacle à la solution
des deux États mais je voudrais rappeler
que avec l'Égypte ce n'a pas empêché un
accord de paix Israël s'est retiré de
tout le Sinaï et à évacuer les colonies
qui étaient sur place également Israël
s'est retiré de
l'entière territoire de l'antier
territoire de de de la bande de Gaza où
il y avait également des des des des
colonies
et c'est justement en pensant que ça
sera en pensant que voilà que si si les
colonies c'est un obstacle à la paix
alors maintenant qu'on qu'on qu'on les
retire de la bande de Gaza on on pourra
avoir la paix vivre en bon voisinage or
ce qu'on ce qu'on a encontré c'est juste
le contraire donc euh la question des
colonies elle devra être résoude dans le
cadre de du processus de paix qui aura
lieu plus tard et Israël comme je dis
bien a déjà prouvé que le cas échéant en
échange d'une véritable paix durable
pourra euh éventuellement évacuer des
des
colonies euh pour l'aide au
développement de l'Union européenne et
de la France euh effectivement si vous
remarquerez qu'en fait l'Autorité
palestinienne reçoive la plus haute aide
euh en du monde si on traduit ça en PER
capit donc vous demandez puis et cela
depuis 50 ans alors moi je m'attendrais
dans ces conditionsl que le l'autorité
palestinenne devienne comme le Singapour
comme Hong Kong c'est c'est vraiment et
et et on voit que c'est pas le cas alors
et je crois que cela démontre sans être
un grand expert en comptabilité qui a un
problème sur la gestion de de cet argent
et un manque de transparence
premièrement au sein de l'Autorité
palestinienne il y a jamais des
discussions dans leur propre Parlement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cet argent
est-ce que c'est destiné pour les pour
les besoins de de notre population et
cetera mais ce qui est plus important
c'est c'est voilà votre devoir vis-à-vis
des contribuables euh qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de cet argent est-ce qu'il est
est-ce qui sert vraiment la cause pour
laquelle on veut
donc notre position c'est pas de de de
de d'arrêter mais mais c'est c'est de
renforcer le le le contrôle pour qu'il
soit un contrôle efficace et que avoir
l'assurance que voilà que chaque euro
qui qui qui est destiné pour pour l'aut
pestienne va à la cause pour laquelle il
est il doit être être destiné merci
c'est aussi c'est aussi et pertinent de
de demander c'est qui va dépenser sur le
terrain est-ce que c'est une
gouvernement un ONG c'est qui sont les
personn qui qui fait cette ONG est-ce
qu'ils
ont le
le le bien vit de de la population
palestinienne et cetera et cetera c'est
pas toujours les cas à propos au unra on
on sait qu'il y a un manifestation de la
haine dans le dans le livre des études
que HRA et imprime depuis des années
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau on a
exprimé de ça vis-à-vis tout les
gouvernement européen tout les
gouvernement occidental et d'aujourd'hui
rien n'était fait alors
c'est voir toute la chaîne de de dépens
on va dire comme ça qui est pas
corrompu et j'ajouterai aussi qu' un
autre problème qui est qui lié à l'aide
au développement mais des associations
c'estd des des ONG et non
gouvernementales parce que vous en fait
vous faites référence à
l'argent l'aide officielle mais il y a
aussi toutes les récoltes d'argent qui
se font dans
des dans des mosquées dans et au sein de
la population musulmane en Europe pour
des associations dites caritatives euh
dans la bande de Gaza et on sait très
bien que ce n'est qu'une couverture pour
détourner de l'argent vers le Hamas et
les moyens existent c'est pas qu'il y a
besoin d'avancer des nouvelles lois de
nouvelles régulations il y a les la
réglementation pour lutter contre le le
branchissement d'argent et la le
financement
de des des des organisations terroristes
sauf que dans le dans le cas précis de
des des les organisations dans la bande
de gazas n'est pas efficacement appliqué
alors donc ça aussi c'est un autre
aspect qui qui qu'il faut traiter
au-delà de l'aide
officielle monsieur le Président je vous
remercie pour m'inviter et je suis à
votre disposition éventuellement pour
futur audition Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
merci beaucoup pour vos propos je
voudrais dire en en conclusion que vous
pouvez voir qu'ici malgré une
représentation j'allais dire éclectique
des différentes compositions qui euh
politique qui qui sont au Sénat il y a
euh en tout cas il n'y a pas de voix
dissonnante et nous appelons les choses
par leur nom et je voudrais saluer
évidemment cette ces prises de position
même si chacun a sa position et son son
point de vue sur les choses don tes
qu'elles doivent se dérouler désormais
et tel qu'elles devront se dérouler en
tout cas il y a trois messages
importants qui je pense sont passés
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il abord un message
d'amitié un message de soutien et puis
également un message d'espoir et ce
message d'espoir il est autour de la
paix que nous espérons tous et au sour
de solutions auxquels chacun et chacune
ici euh espère pouvoir